merci monsieur niche la parole est un
monsieur daniel fasquelle
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au premier ministre
manuel valls monsieur le premier
ministre c'est au nom de 600 salariés de
leur famille que je pose cette après
midi ma question 600 salariés et leurs
familles qui ont fait preuve d'un
incroyable courage et d'une très grande
dignité après la disparition de
seafrance 600 salariés leurs familles
qui ont repris espoir avec la création
d'une scop en 2012 et le lancement de la
compagnie my fair inc 600 salariés leurs
familles qui se sont battus pour
développer l'activité des sociétés avec
de vrais succès sur un marché en pleine
croissance
six ans à l'oeil alors familles avec
lesquelles nous avons défilé à londres
il ya tout juste un an avec natacha
bouchart et les élus de la côte d'opale
pour interpeller l'autorité britannique
de la concurrence qui voulaient interdit
marie frering d'accoster à douvres 600
salariés leurs familles qu'avec leurs
dirigeants se sont battus jusqu'à
obtenir gain de cause le 15 mai dernier
devant la cour d'appel britannique 600
salariés et leurs familles qui sont
aujourd'hui malheureusement complètement
désemparé face à la décision de route
une aile de vendre ses navires et de
signer ainsi l'arrêt de mort de michael
link 600 salariés et leurs familles qui
ne comprennent pas non plus l'incroyable
silence du gouvernement dans ce dossier
alors que vous devriez vous battre pour
défendre les salariés et le pavillon
france à calais est convaincu eurotunnel
de revenir sur sa décision à une
question que je posais en janvier
dernier dans cet hémicycle
le ministre de l'économie me répondez
nous ne pouvons malheureusement rien
cette attitude est incompréhensible et
elle rappelle l'impuissance et la
fameuse phrase de lionel jospin
l'état ne peut pas tout monsieur le
premier ministre
ses 600 salariés et leur famille vous
écoute et leur question est simple
allez-vous une seconde fois face à
l'urgence et au drame
leur dire nous dire que vous ne pouvez
rien faire
la parole est à monsieur alain vidalies
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
de la mer et de la pêche et merci
monsieur le président monsieur fasquelle
au moment où je vous réponds vous savez
que des incidents graves affecte
eurotunnel que les salariés dont nous
parlons utiliser un mode de protestation
que qui n'est pas acceptable la violence
ne sera pas la seule la violence ne sera
pas une solution et notamment pour
eurostar je veux le dire clairement le
ministre de l'intérieur aurait souhaité
vous le dire on peut respecter
l'action des salariés on peut comprendre
ce qui se passe mais aujourd'hui il y à
une situation où on sait très bien que
ce qu'il nous faut c'est être unies
monsieur fasquelle pendant des mois vous
avez posé des questions en parlant comme
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui en
parlant de ce que le gouvernement ne
faisait rien c'était avant la décision
de la cour d'appel britannique comme on
a gagné
alors vous avez fait un communiqué pour
dire que ce grand succès était dû à
votre seul j'ai dit monsieur fasquelle
monsieur fasquelle vous devriez de temps
en temps
de temps en temps vous rappeler cette
phrase de charles péguy qui disait le
triomphe des démagogues est passager
mais les ruines sont éternelles
parce que franchement dans cette
situation aujourd'hui
ce qu'il nous faut c'est être
responsable et fière hier soir hier soir
au conseil municipal de calais tous les
élus de droite et de gauche ont voté une
motion qui va dans le bon sens qui
correspondent complètement ce que le
gouvernement soit souhaite faire et non
pas ce que vous souhaitez faire vous
monsieur fasquelle c'est à dire une
exploitation politicienne sur le malheur
de salariés nous
voulons être aux côtés de ses salariés
chaque fois c'est le gouvernement qui a
réagi et quand vous venez ici dire
qu'est ce que vous faites
qu'est ce que vous proposez je verrai
monsieur vous non vendredi prochain nous
organiserons la table ronde si c'est
nécessaire nous désignerons médiateur si
c'est nécessaire
le gouvernement sera au rendez vous
comme il l'est depuis le début aux côtés
des salariés avec réalisme mais sans
démagogie
merci la séance des questions au
gouvernement et terminer la séance est
suspendue